La tasa de cambio unitaria de "y" con respecto
a "x" es la cantidad que "y" cambia por un
cambio de una unidad en "x".
¿La tasa de cambio unitaria de "y"con respecta
a "x" es menor en la ecuación
"y" igual a "6.5x" o en la gráfica debajo?
Cuando nos hablan de la tasa de cambio unitaria,
podía ser un poco ambiguo, pero en esta pregunta
podemos ver que nos están hablando sobre
la tasa de cambio unitaria de "y" con respecto
a "x" o cuánto cambia "y" en un cambio de
"x",
o sea, cuando "x" tiene un incremento de una unidad.
Y aquí podemos ver que cuando "x" cambia
en una unidad, "y" cambia en 6.5,
cada vez que "x" se incrementa en 1, "y" se va a incrementar en 6.5
o podríamos decir que la tasa de cambio unitaria de "y" con respecto a "x" es de 6.5
para cada cambio de "x" en una unidad .
En la gráfica que tenemos aquí, cuando "x"
cambia en 1, o sea cuando "x" se incrementa
en 1, "y" se incrementa en 3.5 más o menos,
es lo que vemos aquí.
"x" se incrementa en 1 y "y" se incrementa en 3.5.
Así que la tasa de cambio unitaria aquí
en esta gráfica de "y" con respecto a "x"
es de 3.5, para cada cambio de "x" en una
unidad, "y" se incrementa en 3.5.
Entonces vemos que esta línea se incrementa
en una tasa menor que en esta ecuación.
"y" en esta línea se incrementa en una tasa
de cambio unitaria menor
que el incremento que tienen "y"
en esta ecuación con respecto a "x".
La tasa unitaria es menor en la gráfica.